- [Interviewer] All right gorgeous.
Welcome back.
- Thanks.
- [Interviewer] So Rebecca,
how are things?
- [Rebecca] It's awesome.
- [Interviewer] What's going on?
- [Rebecca] Been a long day.
- [Interviewer] You, you're...
The last couple of
times you've been here,`
you were upbeat and very perky.
Today, You're a little bit...
- [Rebecca] Yeah
- A little bit dull.
- [Rebecca] I'm just,
I've been sleeping all night.
I don't usually sleep too much.
So yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you're,
short on sleep right now.
- No.
Like too much sleep.
- [Interviewer] Oh, too much sleep.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And,
but what I...
I mean so, your typical day,
how drug use is...
What...
How big is drug use,
in your day?
- It's not imperative,
but it's there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you typically
you'll wake up and you'll...
Do what?
- I'll wake up,
get high, run around.
- [Interviewer] Your day, you're...
- I just I keep to myself, honestly.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And nobody,
nobody bothers you.
- Mmh.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I mean,
sometimes, you know
what I mean? It happens.
- [Interviewer] But I've never seen you
with black eyes, or bruised up,
or anything like that.
- Mmh.
(mumbles)
- [Interviewer] Do you have...
Do you have
a goal, for yourself.
Or where do you like to be
in a couple of years,
or something like that?
- I already told you that I dunno.
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah.
I dunno.
I forget some of our conversation.
I have so many conversations.
I forget them.
- I said I just want to get
into the fashion industry.
So I just really like the fashion industry
- [Interviewer] Oh, that's right.
You did tell me.
And do you have any,
romantic interests in your life?
- No.
Not right now.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] No?
- There is someone, but I...
It's a little complicated.
- [Interviewer] What does he look like?
- I don't want to talk about it.
- [Interviewer] You don't
wanna talk about it?
Okay.
What do you wanna talk about?
Anything?
- No, no.
You go ahead.
I don't really have anything to say today.
but I've answered that.
- [Interviewer] You get
depressed sometimes?
- Sometimes.
- [Interviewer] Do you,
I mean...
Would you consider yourself
someone who has like,
you know depression
that's
that nags them or...
- I think its just the polarity.
- [Interviewer] Just bipolar,
and stuff.
- I guess yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you go to
the mission sometimes to eat?
- Not really.
- [Interviewer] Where do you,
where do you eat?
- I don't know.
I guess I just kind of like,
I find food,
like I dumpster dive and stuff.
- [Interviewer] You do?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
eating out of a dumpster,
is okay for you?
- I mean, as long as like...
You know what I mean?
Like,
let me put it.
I never really gotten sick like,
I've been very fortunate.
So...
- [Interviewer] You haven't gotten sick?
Yeah.
I mean...
the lack of responsibility
that this lifestyle has,
is that,
is that appealing to you?
Is that why?
- I would suppose so.
It's not about responsibility as much as,
and stuff that closes.
I don't know.
Like...
It's a better way ,
to get to,
understand yourself.
or kind of
be of your own
rather than,
within...
What do they call it?
Like...
Kind of a modality or a pattern.
Or something.
- [Interviewer] Is there
something you're attracted?
I mean,
you told me you'd love Skid Row before.
Is there something about
the fr...
the freedom
or the, or the...
- I think it's just more of an energy.
You know what I mean?
Like, there's...
I'm able to have like,
there's...
There's room for,
self-expression,
without...
Like I don't necessarily need to interact.
I just like, I tend to...
Like I prefer to keep to myself,
lately.
- [Interviewer] I just
wonder if there's a,
a psych medication or something
that you're not taking,
that might help you stabilize,
and maybe help you...
- Not really.
- [Interviewer] No?
- But, you know.
- [Interviewer] I'm not a doctor.
What's the nicest thing
that's happened to you lately?
- Probably just being on myself.
Probably being...
- [Interviewer] What do you
miss about your old life?
- Nothing.
- [Interviewer] Nothing?
- No.
- [Interviewer] What do you hope for?
- Just to keep kind of a base that matter.
To kind of,
keep,
practicing how I'm practicing,
or kind of existing how it feels to,
you know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] And family,
is not part of your life any longer?
- It isn't.
It isn't.
It's not like it's a presence,
but at the same time,
like,
family is really important to me though.
My family are really important to me.
- [Interviewer] They are?
- Yeah.
You know, I really love my family.
- [Interviewer] You love your family?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever
have contact with them?
- Sometimes.
So...
I'm kind of doing what
I'm doing right now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Yeah. That's clear.
Is your family concerned for you?
- I don't really think so.
I'm doing all right.
- [Interviewer] Are you concerned for you?
- Yes and no.
Like,
I like the place that I'm at.
Like, I like
the self sustainability,
but at the same time...
It's like, I'm trying
to find ways to evolve.
Know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] I mean,
I,
I think a lot of my,
viewers have,
see so much potential in you.
Like, I,
every time you come by
they're just like,
"Oh, there's,
there's my friend, Rebecca.
I would love to see,
her just
get her together."
Cause I see so much potential in you.
- That's what I want to do.
- Your personality,
so like...
- Exactly.
- That's what I wanna do,
is just a matter of,
how to communicate it
or how to communicate
what it is that I'm doing.
Because I think there's
so much of what I'm doing,
that's not as understood.
Or it's maybe,
because it's coming from a self where,
it's coming from a place...
Like the way that I practice,
or the way that I exist.
It's not as immediately perceivable.
But at the end of the day, like
I know how I'm going about it
because I'm coming from,
a place of awareness,
or,
maybe attempting to
instigate something new.
You know what I mean?
Rather than,
rely on,
an outdated modem
or an outdated understanding
of how to exist.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
there's been
many, many people I've interviewed
and I would love to see,
a stable,
clear-headed version of down the road.
I would just love to see what you're like,
with your life together.
Maybe like with a little responsibility
a little like,
you know,
discipline,
and like a little bit of like,
a life and
solidity in your life.
- Yeah.
It'd be very interesting
to see who you're,
who you are then.
- [Rebecca] Or just,
or just more,
continuity I guess.
Or something.
- [Interviewer] Something?
- [Rebecca] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Not stability?
- [Rebecca] Like not stability,
but like,
something,
like reliability I guess.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I'm repeating myself
but I just see so much potential in you.
And it's like,
it just seems like it's
it's wasted here on Skid Row.
- [Rebecca] I would...
I would say that I feel like
that I would say that I don't.
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] You're a very interesting,
person.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And you're beautiful.
I think you're,
you're,
your face,
and just your,
energy
and your personality are so likable.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I just hope you,
you get it together somehow.
- I hope so too.
- [Interviewer] I don't know what that is.
- Me, either.
- I don't even know.
- I have no idea.
- [Interviewer] I'm not sure you...
You know.
- It's so much.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Well,
I'm going to give you some lunch money,
and I,
can't wait to see what you're
wearing next time I see you.
- I have to sort through.
- [Interviewer] Stop by anytime.
- Thanks.
- [Interviewer] I'd love to see it.
- [Interviewer] Thanks.
(mumbles)
Okay.
Rebecca, you're back.
- Hi?
- [Interviewer] I love
what you're wearing today.
- Thank you.
Thanks.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you find that?
- I just found it on the floor.
- [Interviewer] You
just found it somewhere?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] The garment
district is right near Skid Row,
so...
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You find
stuff like this sometimes.
Are you in a better mood today?
- Kind of,
kind of.
- [Interviewer] Still kind of down?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] what's going on?
- Like up and down.
I don't know.
It's like,
I feel like something really good
it's going to happen to me,
but like something that
I've been waiting for,
almost.
- [Interviewer] Cool.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's nice
to have that feeling?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's going on?
What's that on your wrist?
Were you in a hospital?
- Yeah, it was...
I was in the hospital.
- [Interviewer] What for?
- I was,
I was feeling kind of suicidal.
- [Interviewer] Oh, no!
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Does that happen
happen often?
- Yeah.
Sometimes.
- [Interviewer] And then what
do they give you for that?
- They,
they didn't give me anything.
It's just kind of this place Exodus
Like you can just kind of
go and relax for a bit.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. I know Exodus.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I've
taken Amanda over there.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What...
So what gets you out of the,
the down mood like that?
- I don't know.
Usually,
- Time?
It just finding...
Yeah.
Just time and yeah...
- [Interviewer] Sometimes sleep helps.
- Yeah,
no I've been...
Cause I've been sleeping a lot,
lately.
Usually,
like when I sleep,
it just kind of like messes with me.
So I'm just kind of ready to get back up,
and...
- [Interviewer] So you're feeling like
more positive right now.
- [Rebecca] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Good.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- [Rebecca] Like it would,
like it was a better morning
than I would have presumed it to be.
- [Interviewer] Good.
- [Rebecca] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Well, I hope you have,
a great,
rest of the day
and week.
And whatever,
good thing you're having your
premonition about is great.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Be careful out there.
- I will. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right,
thanks.
- All right, thanks.